bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france à bruno mais
gardanne le pass sanitaires dont le but
selon le gouvernement et d'accéder à une
vaccination totale de la pub de la
population et il est l'ultime solution
alors l'objectif du pass and it here
n'est pas de vacciner la totalité de la
population mais d'encourager les
personnes qui hésitent encore qui
attendait peut-être la rentrée de
septembre à se faire vacciner le plus
rapidement possible pourquoi parce que
nous sommes dans une course de vitesse
entre invariante delta extrêmement
contagieux à l'origine d'une
augmentation exponentielle des
contaminations survenue un mois et demi
avant ce qui était attendu
et bien sûr cette vaccination qui
semblait stagner avec une sorte de
plafond de verre est donc le pass and i
ter qui devrait être évidemment
uniquement transitoire n'a pour but que
de permettre cette accélération de la
vaccination
évidemment pas toujours des personnes
qui ne souhaiteront pas se faire
vacciner
ça n'est pas le pass vaccinale va leur
permettre alors on voit une forte
contestation contre l'extension de ce
pass sanitaires jean frédéric poisson
justement que vous inspire c'est cette
contestation dans la rue parce qu'elle
est juste isérois je crois qu'il y a
plusieurs éléments qui sont mêlés le
premier d'entre eux c'est certainement
une très grande anxiété alors même que
les français aimeraient profiter de
cette période de vacances pour se
reposer un peu préparé la rentrée dans
de bonnes conditions pour leurs enfants
pour eux-mêmes et cette succession
d'annoncés sur la politique sanitaire et
des restrictions supplémentaires de
liberté
le fait que ces dispositions
apparaissent très très difficilement
applicable pour ne pas dire parfait de
comptes inapplicable dans beaucoup de
cas tout ça provoque beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup d'anxiété chez
beaucoup de personnes qui se demandent
s'il faudra faire vacciner un enfant
comme ils vont aller faire leurs courses
les choses de la vie quotidienne tout à
fait
tout à fait fondamentale tout à fait
basique très concrètes il ya eu une
deuxième chose qui est une forme de
contestation très vive de la politique
sanitaire conduite par le gouvernement
depuis le début et l'orientation
exclusive en faveur de la vaccination de
l'ensemble de la population montre
d'abord ainsi limites
deuxièmement provoque une certaine forme
dans ce village enfin après le variant
delta il y aura sans doute des variants
qui s'appelle route autrement il y en
aura d'ailleurs probablement de plus en
plus ils sont d'ailleurs de plus en plus
dangereux parce que si la logique même
des variants et donc il ya ce sentiment
que chez beaucoup de nos compatriotes et
chez moi en particulier que on est en
train encore une fois de mettre le doigt
dans quelque chose qu'on ne maîtrise pas
et dernier point tout cela a pour
résultat le fait que et bien un certain
nombre de nos libertés les plus
fondamentales sont remises en cause et
je je je loue la mesure la modération du
professeur bégard balle que j'entends
par ailleurs souvent qu'il a confiance
dans la médecine et dans la science il a
d'ailleurs sans doute raison qui comment
dire kung fu chi qui nous dit au fond
nous arrivons à vaincre ce virus était
le déni pourquoi pas très bien mais
certainement pas de mon point de vue en
tout cas en rabotant comme c'est le cas
une fois de plus les libertés
individuelles et fondamentale des
français et je pense est consulté cette
contestation pardon être une forme de
synthèse de ces trois éléments que je
viens de décrire un bruno mes gars ben
justement sur la privation des libertés
individuelles
qu'est ce que vous dites vous qui êtes
chef du service de réanimation de
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris
alors évidemment j'entends tout à fait
que la position d'un pas sanitaires on
va dire en termes très légèrement la
liberté individuelle de façon
transitoire mais le but est en fait de
permettre à plus long terme de garantir
la liberté de tous dans la sécurité à
nouveau tous les lieux qui seront régies
par le passage terre seront garants de
l'absence de
risque de contamination d'ailleurs le
pass anita permettra bien sûr le
maintien de ces vies de lieux de ces
deux séries de ces lieux de vie sociale
d'interaction de ces lieux déterminés et
je me permets juste de vous interrompre
parce qu'on a vu que dans les
discothèques premier lieu où le passager
tara est donc encore entré en vigueur
ça fonctionne pas forcément il ya
beaucoup de contamination et avec la
star alors non je je je je je suis pas
d'accord c'est plutôt leur verse il n'y
aurait pas eu le pass sanitaires il y
aurait des clusters dans chaque boîte de
nuit ouverte donc la sanction ont été
immédiatement de fermer la totalité des
boîtes de nuit du territoire le fait
qu'il y ait eu quelques kloster dans
certaines boîtes de nuit reflète
simplement la mauvaise application en
raison très probablement de fraudes de
se passe à lithaire c'est à dire des
personnes qui sont entrées dans la boîte
de nuit sans avoir validé le fameux pass
sanitaires jean frédéric poisson on a vu
des gilets jaunes dans les cortèges
parisiens aujourd'hui et c'est une
journée mobilisation qu'elle nationale
contre l'extension de ce passé sanitaire
qu'est ce que cela dit sur l'atmosphère
qui règne aujourd'hui en france et je
pense qu'il y à jeux j'y reviens et je
rebondirai juste après sur ce que vient
de délocalisation mais carbone il y a
une grande fatigue des français après un
an et quelques de confinement
déconfinement comment dire empêchement
du désordre aux libertés quotidienne
mais réelle à facilités de la vie tous
les jours il y as deuxièmement une
espèce de sidération devant le caractère
très difficilement compréhensible les
annonces successives du gouvernement
alors je ne refais pas l'historique de
la gestion de la crise sanitaire mais il
est difficile de s'y retrouver de savoir
effectivement ce qu'on a besoin de faire
peindre à le faire ce qui fonctionne et
ce qui ne fonctionne pas nous sommes
encore dans une très grande apesanteur
sûr
sur ces sujets il par ailleurs je viens
d'entendre ce que ce que je viens
d'évoquer le professeur
moi je n'ai pas compris en tout cas les
fabricants eux-mêmes des vaccins ne
garantissent pas que le fait d'être
vacciné empêche la contamination c'est à
dire empêche de d'être contaminé par le
virus ni empêche de le transmettre
donc cette espèce de confiance l'une
mène d'une certaine manière absolue dans
la logique vaxillaire tout ça tout ça
paraît disproportionnée je pense que les
français comprennent bien ça il n'est
pas nécessaire d'avoir fait très longues
études de sciences pour simplement
entendre ce que les différents
intervenants disent à ce sujet les gilet
jaune sont dans la rue parce que on voit
bien et on comprend très bien que tous
les à côtés de cette crise sanitaire je
veux dire là l'explosion de la dette
publique je veux dire là les
conséquences sur la vie socio économique
sur leurs emplois sur leur vie
quotidienne en pour une fois ne fait
qu'aggraver les circonstances qui ont
motivé leur détermination et leur
mobilisation il ya maintenant deux ans
maintenant on retrouve comment dire dans
les mêmes cortèges ceux qui sont tout
simplement fatigué parce que cette
gestion de la crise sanitaire pour des
bonnes et pour de mauvaises raisons
lisa épuisé exténués et ça rejoint ce
qui était déjà auparavant avant cette
liste à lithaire déjà fatigués par les
circonstances socio économique de leur
vie quotidienne et d'une certaine
manière le manque de considération qu'il
subissait c'est il ya une espèce de
conjonction de volonté qui se
manifestent aujourd'hui dans la rue et
je pense qu'il n'ira qu'en s'amplifiant
parce que il n'y a aucune raison que le
mois d'août
ni la rentrée scolaire et la rentrée
sociale du mois de septembre prochain
atténue ces différentes circonstances
bruno mégarde à l'explosion des cas de
contamination en france en tout cas n'y
a pas d'explosion de personnes en
réanimation du nombre de personnes en
réanimation est ce que on peut
véritablement aujourd'hui établir ce
lien entre la vaccination et la
situation dans les services à critique
alors tout d'abord effectivement
l'objectif principal de la vaccination
c'est de protéger les individus contre
les formes graves voire
tels de lakovic 19 il annoncé il faut le
répéter les vaccins actuellement
disponibles protège quasiment à 100%
contre ces formes
il ya donc un intérêt direct bénéfice
direct de l'individu à se faire vacciner
ensuite je voudrais juste préciser pour
monsieur poisson effectivement les
vaccins réduisent le risque de
transmission pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement même s'ils n'empêchent
pas le fait d'être soi même contaminer
les contaminations se font avec des
charges virales tellement au film que la
personne ne peut pas ne peut pas être
contaminées en tout cas la capacité de
contamination est considérablement
réduite
probablement / 15 d'après les derniers
chiffres
alors vous avez raison actuellement nous
observons une progression exponentielle
des contaminations et la question est de
savoir est ce que ces contaminations
vont se traduire par une progression des
admissions à l'hôpital est en
réanimation
alors on voit déjà commencé à arriver
quelques patients en réanimation
bien sûr les chiffres sont extrêmement
pas et pour le moment il n'y a aucune
alerte au corps au niveau de l'hôpital
mais est ce que ceci va durer dans le
temps est ce qu il ne va pas y avoir une
vague hospitalière avec une progression
exponentielle et une menace sur notre
système de santé
eh bien on ne le sait pas c'est ça le
problème on ne le sait pas avec
certitude car niveau actuel la
vaccination de la population
eh bien on ne peut pas le garantir mais
évidemment on espère la vaccination va
permettre de découpler la progression
des contaminations de celle des cas
d'hospitalisation
c'est tout ce que l'on souhaite melian
bruno b gavanon vous suit va très bien
je vais donner la parole à jean frédéric
poisson dans un instant on vous suit
très bien mais on voit aussi que toute
cette contestation dans la rue elle
montre qu'il ya des problèmes de
compréhension
vis-à-vis de s'obstiner terres de son
utilité et peut-être que le gouvernement
il donne l'impression qu'on souhaite
finalement forcé les français à se faire
vacciner puisque vous dites vous que le
but ce n'est pas une vaccination total
de la population ici n'est en fait le
but c'est encourager à la vaccination
les personnes qui hésitent
bien sûr en les accompagnant
d'explications pédagogiques
je ne dis pas que on va dire
l'information se fait de façon optimale
et malheureusement eu beaucoup de ces
personnes qui sont dans les
manifestations qui sont vaccinaux
sceptiques et bien se base sur un
certain nombre d'informations pseudo
scientifiques qui circule sur internet
sur les réseaux sociaux
il est vrai qu'on pourrait améliorer la
diffusion de l'information
je suis d'accord avec vous est peut-être
organiser des émissions de débats entre
des autorités scientifiques et des
personnes qui avancent des thèses rooney
pour montrer là où se trouve la vérité
évidemment jean frédéric poisson alors
je voudrais je remercie brevet sur mega
man de prendre soin indirectement de la
santé moi je suis pas du tout vaccinaux
sceptique je fais partie d'une
génération qui est allé à l'école
primaire avec le vaccin de bêtises et
sur l'épaule
j'ai fait mon service militaire j'ai été
activée contre l'état de choses j'ai eu
la chance de voyager dans plusieurs
dizaines de pays dans le monde entier
dans l'hémisphère nord comme dans
l'hémisphère sud
donc à peu près toutes les maladies
tropicales et cetera je les ai injecté
où on me les a injecté et les vaccins en
tout cas contre ces maladies il ya une
différence avec les différents vaccins
sur la colline c'est que je me permets
de rappeler et si parfaitement
vérifiables par tous tous les vaccins
qui sont aujourd'hui proposés aux
français sont encore sous le coup d'une
autorisation des deux demi sur le marché
on va dire qui est transitoire
temporaire la validation de ces produits
n'est pas aujourd'hui complètement
achevés et moi je préfère être dans la
situation dans laquelle je me ferai
vacciner lorsque je constaterai
qu'effectivement si différents produits
ont satisfait aux différentes étapes de
contrôle par lesquels ils doivent pas
s'il pourrait être définitivement validé
aujourd'hui ces produits ne le sont pas
s'il est en tout cas
le sens des textes officiels portes il y
compris par le ministère de la santé
pour l'instant la progression de la
contamination
chers éditeurs les charges des
professeurs m'égare bonne elle pose deux
problèmes et vous avez raison de
rappeler que la capacité de nos hôpitaux
est en jeu mais d'une certaine façon je
me permettrai insisté sur le fait qu' on
connaît des traitements précoces qui
permettent de guérir de la maladie avant
d'entrer dans une phase grave et donc
donné de nécessité une hospitalisation
des personnes qui sont contaminées
l'institut pasteur a rappelé il ya pas
très longtemps qui vient meltin pouvait
avoir plus qu'un intérêt pour soigner de
manière précoce des patients puis
deuxièmement la saturation de l'hôpital
et a évidemment une question essentielle
et je ne met en cause ni la compétence
internationale de santé qui nous file ni
leur dévouement
je dis simplement si cet aprem de
capacité alors pas de nous des moyens à
l'hôpital d'accueillir de manière
suffisante les personnes qui sont
concernées
enfin il ya il y a quand même autour de
ce pass sanitaire plusieurs problèmes
extrêmement concret et je me mets
maintenant comment dire pleinement et
complètement d'un brin de responsables
politiques et en étant attentif aux
droits il faut prendre la peine de lire
le texte qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale et qui est débattu
au sénat
en ce moment même il y à une suite de
mesures parfaitement incohérentes
selon les types de transport les types
de magasins les types d'activités enfin
personne de comprendre comment ça
fonctionne ils voient bien que fonds
devraient être alertés par le fait que
quand un dispositif comme le passé a dit
terry si difficile à mettre en place
si difficile à faire respecter par tous
ceux qui sont intéressés à cela quand
ils provoquent des torsions à notre
droit au point d'inventer une faute
comment dire qu'ils justifient le
licenciement d'un salarié ne seraient
pas vaccinés alors là je me dis qu'on
est très au delà de simples objectifs
politiques sanitaires et que ça va
beaucoup trop loin et que si parce que
le gouvernement ait pouvoir exécutif
vont trop loin que beaucoup de français
sont dans la rue aujourd'hui avec tout
plein et entier soutien
bruno m'égare ban alors que l'on voit
comme un relais clé des champs elysées
eh bien le canon à eau et se positionne
son approche donc de la dispersion de la
manifestation
bruno m'égare ban sur la fiabilité des
des vaccins est-ce que vous pouvez nous
nous préciser que évidemment les vaccins
sont fiables en tout cas ça a été quand
même le fruit de longues de recherche
quand même scientifique
alors on va dire nous avons la chance
énorme de disposer aussi rapidement de
vaccins pour nous protéger contre une
maladie extrêmement grave
imaginons qu'elle quelle aurait été la
situation sanitaire aujourd'hui et pour
les deux ou trois ans qui viennent si
nous ne disposions pas de vaccin
regardons ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé en inde récemment ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en tunisie en indonésie et
dans d'autres pays c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire
ces personnes ne font que réclamer la
vaccination pour être protégé
malheureusement pour nous aujourd'hui
celle le vaccin démontré son intérêt
préventif
il ne faut pas croire à l'existence de
médicaments capables d'éviter
l'évolution grave de la maladie
on l'aurait tout souhaité évidemment
malheureusement l'ivermectine ne
fonctionne pas les études cliniques
sérieuse les méta-analyses ne démontre
aucun bénéfice de l'ivermectine en
termes d'évolution de la maladie
bien sûr il ya quelques études
expérimentales chez le hamster qui
montre quelques effets immunomodulateurs
et c'est le sens de l'étude de
l'institut pasteur de l'ivermectine mais
en rien ça ne modifie l'évolution d'un
patient porteur de lakovic 19 vers le
risque de faire une forme grave voire
une forme mortelle et c'est ça l'intérêt
car le vaccin lui effectivement permet
de prévenir tout sans merci en tout cas
à bruno mais gardanne chef du service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris merci à vous également jean
frédéric poisson
d'avoir répondu à nos questions